louder with a crowd here we come right
back
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
oh that's surprising alarm I don't know
if you know this occasionally we
actually do have non-branded drinkware
so when I drive here and this is a
non-branded tumbler so I please don't
sue me blender bottle
uh we have a lot to get to today it's a
it's a big day it's a fun you know what
one of my favorite days and the reason
why is because we have gay William in
studio oh that's right gay William in
studio to talk about uh Kevin Bacon uh
wants to touch your kids
emotionally with drag queens who touch
them physically so we'll be talking
about that not only that but what's
going on now with drag shows where they
will not host them unless they are with
your children sorry if this matters this
is legislative the most important topic
I think today that we're going to be
getting into and you cannot let this
happen so please hit the like button
right now share this show if you can
because fauci and Trudeau and of course
their complicit media are trying to say
that they never actually advocated for
lockdowns or forced people to get
vaccines the only way the left wins long
term is if you let that go it's ah let's
take the high road no no we have to
remember it and you just like rubbing a
dog's face in their own feet you gotta
go no no remember this right here
remember the lockdown remember the
vaccine mandate remember the black face
there you go love it take it that's what
you have to do
and uh we'll also be talking about
about Donald Trump and DeSantis and the
attacks that have ramped up I know some
of you are interested in that I'm not so
interested in that but I know you are so
uh Gerald a how are you sir I'm doing
well it's it's a post-sip world my
friend do your sip I didn't do my sip
because Nick's like if he does that sip
one time I swear to God I'm gonna walk
out really I'm gonna walk out I didn't
know that was did he become an Irishman
there was a little bit here he is he's
from he is actually Irish I am there was
a little bit of Dane Cook in there that
wasn't I swear to God if you take a ship
I'm gonna walk out
oh I hate when he takes the Sip I hate
when he goes ship oh no sippy poop sip
the shocker yeah
how do you do Dane Cook rage yes pretty
much
someone phone here someone vibrate by
the way how are you doing I'm good I
didn't ask you I normally I but I was so
thrown off by the nonsense Oh I'm great
I'm great you know what I love is I love
that now my my little boy just loves
wrestling and he comes up yeah well that
could be good enough to go either way
well as long as he doesn't go into it
professionally well but he doesn't know
what I meant but okay he does a little
Macho Man Randy Savage now where he
comes up he goes wrestling and I go yeah
what do you want to do he goes oh yeah
and I go oh yeah yeah you're the cream
of the crap oh he goes oh yeah and he
throws himself in the back wait till he
goes this is when you get concerned when
he goes Sandusky
no moving on you pen what what pencil I
don't even know what it was all right so
let me ask you this question today what
is your favorite covid conspiracy theory
that came true you can comment below and
uh you've already heard him but you love
him he has his own theme song because he
is in uh Daytona Beach Florida on
Rollerblades the Hilton Oceanfront May
12th and then of course he is also May
19th 25th hyenas in Dallas go to
nickdapaloshow.com the funniest man
alive Nick De Paula how are you sir
tremendous Stephen how are you you look
can I just say this via fans they got to
be hockey fans right you have a lot of
sure
uh does Stephen is he not the spitting
image of Tom Wilson of the Washington
Capitals who's the baddest ass in the
league by the way that's High Praise I'm
[Music]
not Tom Wilson the senator he was
addicted you are an unknown hockey
player right I know my ass I thought I
looked like Tom Wilkins come on Gerald
he's not Patrick this guy no thank God
he's not this guy is a he first of all
he's the toughest guy in the league and
he's a great hockey player I mean they
rely on him well they can bring it up in
the control room later and let the
audience absolutely but thank you I
appreciate the compliment I'm just
saying I have a crush on you go ahead
did you ever watch the documentary on
Bob Probert could you watch the
documentary I didn't have to I sold him
as Cocos
[Laughter]
so fast when he fought what a badass he
was he's a I read a list of toughest
guys in history they got him at number
one and about 10 lists a friend of our
family Stu Grimson had to fight him no
Stu Grimson yeah actually it's funny it
was hockey okay can I can I do this I'll
just look so hockey Ministries this was
something we were kids where it's like
underprivileged kids and then and my dad
yeah yeah a lot of hockey in Iran
another two minutes she was doing
Turkish oil wrestling
see that they do that in the Middle East
it's shirtless oil wrestling they're
like yeah yes we like wrestling but you
need to lube them up move them up for
the takedown so it's hockey it's like
underprivileged kids a lot of time and
it's a Christian hockey camps they do
like Bible studies and stuff and teach
kids you know skill sets and then they
bring in a pro to coach and my dad was
one of the stable coaches and then one
year was Stu Grimson and he came in and
um he talked about with Bob Probert
because Stu was a tough guy yeah he was
he said and this is true
and I've known people like this and
sometimes I can be this way but he said
you know the thing is with Stu said with
Bob Probert
you know you have what is it 80 games in
a season yeah like that he said yeah you
knew whenever you were about to face Bob
Probert his team
it wasn't that he was a good fighter it
was that he was a man with complete
disregard for his own personal safety or
well-being and he wasn't going to stop
until you put him down and he said and
living with a man like that in your head
for 48 hours is a very difficult life to
live yeah that's called a good fight of
the qualities you mentioned yeah but he
he just because Stu was a was a smart
guy just imagine this is a guy who was
willing to break himself and he was a
good scorer yeah all right speaking of a
score
see the little segue there it was
beautiful Nick and I called it a Segway
so it's beautiful like the guy who
invented the Segway and segued off a
cliff
that's how he died right no the guy
invented the second always segued off a
cliff can I see footage of that I
haven't jerked off
I'm sorry I forgot this is the early
part of the show I'm serious I'm sorry
it'll be fine
I guess you can't take that out either
this is like streaming yeah yeah so if
you've heard of live yeah I'm I'm sorry
but he's like what is what's streaming
what is that oh it's live I don't even
know how to tell people to get to your
show yeah I know I go just drive to you
know where and see it live yeah drive to
Dick's Sporting Goods
the Schenectady airport that plays on
every screen next to dot whatever Don
lemon's right now okay so I'm sorry
we've dragged out we've wasted your time
but you know what that's part of it so
Barbie Mattel in order to boost
inclusivity just announced
and at one point you would have thought
this was a sketch all references are
available for you at lotto's credit.com
this is real they just announced uh the
release
I feel bad even saying it Down syndrome
barbius
children the opportunity to play with
more inclusive dolls
this doll is breaking barriers
fashion doll yeah with strength
allowing more children to project their
future through fashion doll play and
imagine what is possible Mattel Barbie's
parent company announced
well here's the thing they really have
been going full board Mattel actually
announced plans to expand this in the
name of diversity before the end of the
year with sickle cell Barbie so that's
something they also you know look
everyone's
everyone's involved Down syndrome Barbie
short bus not included did she have to
say did she have to say smash through
barriers when we all know about special
needs strength I mean
I looked at the Barbie and I'm like
shot she doesn't look that downsy
exactly that's my whole point it looks
like Amy Schumer
says this is the Down Syndrome Barbie
and it's like here another Barbie to
sell like I feel like I'm being taken
advantage of now with more yeah
that's why I promise professional
assistant not included Lena Dunham
weird I don't know by the way if you see
this or hear this on YouTube because I'm
sure we've already had to hit it uh this
means
that's what's going on is still on on
Rumble so we don't have to self-censor
on YouTube and it's a live show Monday
through Friday 10 a.m Eastern Friday
only on mug Club the rest of the time on
Rumble and uh we encourage you to watch
we do not get to do this without you
we're funded by viewers like you at mug
Club unlike NPR who's funded by tax
dollars monkey pox Ken can we get to
that yes
unfair he drives it's inclusive drives
us convertible and skin flakes just
flying off
can we get the Barbie in the face yeah
oh no gosh what do you have leprosy no I
just I went to a Norwegian techno
Festival right how about the 42 suicide
oh yeah that was yes I'm sorry if we're
going there let's go there it comes with
a nice sailor's knot yeah there's a new
scenario every room in the Barbie
Dreamhouse
laughs
when it comes with a little eight ball
that says not today look look here's the
thing I have worked with you know the
special needs people for for years
they sit in there yeah well that's just
called taking advantage it's called
grooming Dave
it's called grooming little ladies
none of them ever thought I I don't feel
represented right they never complained
about it they were totally fine they
were totally fine with their toys
because Barbie is just like chubby girls
weren't going Barbie's too thin right
exactly I mean Barbie allows me to live
a full life apparently is yeah but dang
it and she's gonna clip this and I know
sorry dang it all right so you guys can
comment if you you know look if you have
a kid with Down syndrome and you're
really happy about Down syndrome
Barbie's great good for you I just think
that it's stupid yes and I mean stupid
like cool like yo that's stupid I mean
that's stupid unintelligent I thought
you guys are doing a parody of a
commercial I know I I know some of the
stuff exists but that one even went a
little I I mean yeah it's look we need
it it was needed but now we have it so
everything is good so let's move on to a
story I think is also really important
here yeah
um remember covid yes remember that
remember that was the thing and some of
you may not know uh some of you who
maybe were a little bit younger uh the
entire world got locked down yeah right
they were locked down uh then there were
vaccine mandates it upended the economy
unemployment to numbers that we've never
seen in our lifetime the fundamental
shifting of the economy all on the word
of the few experts and of course the
lackeys who said trust the science and I
know that right now this isn't super
topical right and everyone always wants
to jump on the trend and the trend in
the trend but I think this is probably
the most important subject we covered
today why the only way the left wins is
if there is no sunlight they squirm
anytime there's transparency they squirm
anytime they're called to the mat to
answer for their actions and they want
you to now actually believe in their
complicit media right in the industrial
entertainment media complex they want
you to believe that they never did all
of those things so let me sort of lead
the way here Halloween 2022 the Atlantic
started running cover right and that's
for the expert class the all the the
science yeah right the science that they
called it trademark marked they read an
article called called let's declare a
pandemic amnesty now this article
implored readers to quote forgive the
experts for their misguided
recommendations and mandates so these
are some of the things they said we have
to put these fights aside and declare a
pandemic amnesty we can leave out the
willful purveyors of actual
misinformation while forgiving the hard
calls that people had no choice but to
make with imperfect knowledge yeah I
have to stop them right there I read the
beginning of that article and I'm like
no you're lying you said you were on a
hiking trail with cloth masks that you
made for your family that there was a
signal that the lead hiker would give if
anybody was coming close where you would
put the masks on and you had no idea
that cloth masks wouldn't work I did a
guided tour with them and it didn't work
because they were doing Navy singles I
only know the Air Force signals well
that's that's apparently true you did
the bicycling stop
yesterday I saw the guy doing this the
bicycle stop I saw him unironically
doing this and I just I mean I ran him
over I was gonna say please tell me you
took a hard ride into his bike yes I did
so don't let them tell you that we
didn't know these things we've known it
for a hundred years lockdowns were
actually not recommended by The Who
immediately sorry and I know we're going
to get into people saying this but but
they weren't the same part it was a CDC
and it was fouchy exactly so uh let's go
to uh I guess let's start with now what
they're saying okay these experts versus
them so it's a matter of record and it's
irrefutable and hopefully you can use
this with your friends because watch the
conversation change remember just don't
forget don't think did I dream that all
your friends now who are saying oh you
know we didn't know no they did know
those same people at your dinner meeting
at your Thanksgiving dinners were saying
we have to lock down can you believe
that Republicans are going to spread
this remember we were providing
information at that point in time while
the experts were giving you one side now
they're acting as though they never had
access to this information it's not true
it's just like fauci when he said age
was airborne and other scientists said
no it's not but he was in a position of
authority so now we have uh prime
minister uh blackface in Chief Justin
Trudeau University of Ottawa on Monday
said that he actually never forced
anyone to get vaccinated
foreign
[Applause]
okay sorry wrong clip uh here's the
right the scientists and the medical
experts and the researchers not just in
Canada but around the world
understood that vaccination was going to
be the way through this
and therefore while not forcing anyone
to get vaccinated I chose to make sure
that all the incentives and all the
protections were there to encourage
Canadians to get vaccinated and that's
exactly what they did we got vaccinated
to a higher level than just about any
other of our Peer Country yeah yeah
threatening people with jail time and
freezing their bank accounts it was just
incentives uh like a rapist's gun
laughs
it's the same what's that what's that
it's incentive to sleep with me I
am an entrepreneur
don't you ain't you ever heard a
quantitative easing the point is
this is this is what they say it's
incentives oh isn't that a nice isn't
that a nice just term now these were
incentives freezing bank accounts and
ruining yeah that's not an incentive no
so let's go back to they're trying to
memory hole you back then
prime minister blackface who did it like
nine times the thing about the fact that
this guy has been forgiven it just shows
you none of this selective outrage is
real this guy did it more times than you
probably wear an outfit period in your
life blackface what times and I did it
yes well
I mean depends on which years we're
taking which Seasons but you know it's
certainly close yes
and we love you for it so back then
Trudeau
he actually made it so that people
couldn't even go about their day at all
without getting the vaccine this is them
on their nose because I can't go
anywhere I can't do
and more restrictions are on the way
Justin Trudeau is promising vaccine
mandates for the federal public service
and for travelers we're going to make
sure in the coming weeks that anyone 12
or older who wants to get on a plane or
a train come to my house
September 21st of 2021 yep a year and a
half into the pandemic he was very proud
of it too yes so from this now say I
never forced anyone and by the way let's
also uh here's another then so you know
prime minister blackface described and
we're going to get to fauci he described
people protesting the vaccine mandates
which by the way why would you need to
protest anything there's no vaccine
mandate which is what he's saying now he
described the people protesting the
vaccine mandate the vaccine mandate
which is a figment of your imagination
as disgusting sub-human and to Canadians
at home
watching and disgust and disbelief at
this Behavior wondering how this could
have happened in our nation's capital
after everything we've been through
together
this is not the story of our pandemic
of our country of our people the two
worst human beings that I have ever seen
in politics that man and Governor
Whitmer in Michigan yeah people there
are people who disagree with there are
people who you can tell just get off on
Power and abusing it he's one of them
yeah and he's he's so weak he's
dangerous because he's going to have to
do something to make himself look strong
like freezing the bank accounts of
truckers and saying that they're
disgusting people again I'll give you
the timeline about a year into the
pandemic yeah we didn't know anything
then come on are you serious yeah at
that point well guess what they were
removing
us from YouTube from Facebook from
Twitter if we said that hey these
actually these these lockdowns don't
work the who doesn't recommend them that
was one of the suspensions no lockdowns
according to who also denied that um you
know the Taiwan again the first one on
the very first
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
again this is a PG-13 show I'm pretty
sure I know what Nick's going to say
after this no no you know what do it do
it Nick I think you let your freak flag
fly so pregnant but Deputy Prime
Minister uh Christia Freeland whoa
that's not an insult she's a lady oh
her part I thought it was a guy sorry uh
vowed to quote ruin truckers who
protested against the vax mandates which
by the way they now say never happened
in February 2022.
if your truck is being used in these
protests your corporate accounts will be
frozen
the insurance on your vehicle will be
suspended the consequences are real
and they will bite
it is time for you to go home neck
opinions on that broad uh speaking of
Frozen she's like she looks like Ted
Williams head
I you know people be going I live in
Canada everything's frozen go ahead yeah
ugly witch
with her I was hoping you wouldn't I
don't know if you look up what do you
think what do you think are pictures
next to what in the dictionary oh it
begins with a c and it ends in a t again
yeah yeah right content
I thought you were going to say punt I
mean
I was looking for one today that woman I
could not stand there thank you Nick
PG-13 I guess but the it's a new 13.
it's pg48 it's the American it's the uh
American Psycho PG-13 yes nc-13 that's a
13 year old pirate yes I
she's a marvelous gosh that's my
new favorite go-to I learned that one
from The Sopranos and uh we're going to
go to faucier but comment below
especially if you're from Canada if
you're from Canada look you are the
sample pool if you're on Rumble if
you're on YouTube you comment and people
will get to see it the beauty is you can
now comment on the mandates you can now
comment on the lockdowns and criticize
them because they're trying to say that
they never existed so at least that
opens it up to conversation let's go to
fauci everyone's favorite marionette who
wants to be a real boy here's what he is
saying now in a New York Times interview
um fauci tried to avoid any of the blame
for the lockdowns he said show me a
school that I shut down and show me a
factory that I shut down never I never
did I never did never ever did I did I
did
I gave a public health recommendation
that echoed the cdc's recommendation and
people made a decision based on that he
he also added something clearly went
wrong I don't know exactly what that was
it's science we can cast we can take a
guess that's like a mob boss saying I
never ordered that that's right come on
did that it's very mob-like isn't it
when you think of we're going to shut
down your bank accounts yeah we're just
going to make it so that you can't
purchase anything we're going to make it
so you can't travel and you know you do
whatever you want yeah you can't flee
this persecution to at least get
somewhere where you can live oh you want
to come back you want to go visit your
family uh in Europe we're gonna lock you
down for 14 days in a quarantine and you
know maybe you show back up maybe you
don't
so that's what he's saying now fauci
let's go back in case you didn't know
but the the record matters back then
fauci was I mean I wish I loved anything
as much as fauci loved using lockdowns
to stop the virus I would like to see a
dramatic diminution of the personal
interaction that we see in restaurants
and in bars whatever it takes to do that
oh sorry I had to blow my nose I have
that red tide yep still red tide yep you
sure it's not covered I have no idea and
I don't care here's another clip of then
again keep in mind right now we have no
idea I didn't show me anything that I
shut down back then he urged lockdowns
to coerce people into getting the
vaccination here you go
has its consequences you use lockdowns
to get people
oh so lockdowns to stop the spread of
covid and then lockdowns to force people
to get the vaccine that just to be clear
that's two different instances of
lockdowns what he wants to tell you what
he wants you to believe is show me a
factory I shut down like he's a foreman
right exactly he didn't walk in and
order it but basically he said look
that's a vaccine passport ad right there
that's basically saying hey you want to
live your life you want to go to work
you want to be able to make a living and
feed your family and also be able to
protect them and provide home and
security for them uh maybe you should
get this jab otherwise you can't do any
of that yeah yeah it's Hitler saying
show me a Jewish uh score it is right
exactly that's exactly
and othering anyone who doesn't get the
vaccine sounds much better in bavariance
yeah no does he was uh he was very
charismatic
it's a headliner yeah that guy could
draw yeah he just showed up I'm not
going to MC night night you think I'm a
Midler I
think a little bit inside baseball for
people who've had to live to surprise
swallowing siege that is the stand-up
circuit it only succeeded we could have
avoided all exactly yeah
it's safe over here yeah we got a priest
over here praising the third right yeah
exactly Gerald's Final Solution if he
could if he could clip it use it a
letter from Paul to the third right
[Laughter]
SS
slavery was okay
pound it okay
I hate all I get it with fouchy look it
takes a big man to admit to that he's
wrong but thought she's five five so you
can't expect it
and if you're still
wondering by the way
again this is these are the real life
consequences of lies from people in
positions of authority here's the thing
some homeless guy lies and you don't he
has no effect it's when you centralize
power to unelected officials who are
free to lie as it by the way serves to
mandate policy that you have a problem
this is why when people say oh I'm
pro-free speech but their solution is
socialism I like that people are further
[Music]
foreign
look and and by the way share the show
if you're this is this is I'm sure has
mostly been dumped on YouTube yes is
that because it made seriously no no
absolutely not mostly it's usually
Gerald oh really you can say naughty
words you can't say that the CDC says
that the flu is more dangerous than
covet for kids the more I find out about
Gerald more I like about that I know ah
he's like a dick cabin if he were a
sociopath that's right
what if I were sociopath yeah yeah I'm
not sure that's good with anybody well
it's good for us it could be like you're
a who cares and a sociopath yeah well I
mean it's good for us but you know let's
we'll keep an eye on child protective
services so
what you can't do is let them this is
why when people say hey why do you break
look don't let the memory hold this this
is this is an actual legal a a political
as a matter of policy version of
gaslighting they come out right fauci
and by they I do mean the left why you
got to say left man okay is anyone on
the right trying to get you to forget
about lockdowns and vaccine mandate
maybe you have a couple your Mitch
McConnells of the world but I would
consider them among the left they're
certainly not allies of mine they'd want
you to actually believe that they never
hey the next step on it to actually blow
my nose like fully
it's like there's remnants
[Laughter]
they want you to believe that they never
did these things and the media says good
enough for us let's just tell people
that you never did now here is again we
talked about the real life consequences
the lockdowns had real-life consequences
the vaccine mandates had real-life
consequences remember when they were
saying locking down just to be safe just
to be safe as though there were no risks
we were talking about this you can go
back and check the references the
percentage of children by the way
reaching expected levels of learning
fell dramatically pre-pandemic 72
percent to 59 math scores in 2022 so the
largest decrease ever suicide attempts
skyrocketed from 2019 to 2021 teen
suicide went up by 51 percent the
economy was devastated in a way that you
could have never pictured the first year
of the pandemic 200 000 more businesses
than normal permanently closed
permanently 2020 the worldwide economy
shrank by an estimated five sorry eight
is it 8.5 8.5 trillion dollars that's
nine percent of the total economy
because that little Geppetto son of a
decided that he wanted to but not
go into the factory like Officer and a
Gentleman right that's what he wants you
to think like I never went into the
factory and closed it down because of
you the expert the science and all your
cabal like Nick says 10 people in a room
yeah you devastated the world and now
you want us to think that it was our
fault I guess I just shut down my
business permanently I I don't know why
I did that no I just like silly me they
hold me off to jail when I I was open on
a Saturday but I guess that was my fault
it's a dry rehearsal for what's coming
next I swear to God they just want to
see how far they could push oh I do no I
do but I'm just saying they want her to
see how much we would obey how much we
would take yeah they were
laughing yeah remember the first thing
they told us don't touch our eyes yeah
remember that one yeah it was horrible
that's one of my Main Hobbies yeah I was
gonna say were you touching your eyes
before covert were you going to 100 put
on your pants I don't need you
[Laughter]
my friends go who's responsible for the
pandemic I go it was horrible for me
because I like to role-play I like to
role play Clockwork Orange
yeah don't touch your eyes yeah sanitize
your packages don't punch your wife come
on I mean you know look they know no
bounds here's the thing so the first
Salvo is basically oh we we didn't
actually say these things and what we're
seeing sprinkled in now is well we just
didn't have enough information yes we
did yeah they were just guessing when we
said this all of this information was
available and you decided to bury it
they were they're the ones saying follow
the science right they came up with that
phrase exactly so you had plenty of
information exactly but that's what's
most important I always say it's not
what decisions did they make in the
absence of information right what
decisions did they make when that
information was available and they
denied it anyway it's not like there
were no this is what they do with global
warming right 97 of scientists which is
statistic in other words when
they say hey the Kyoto Protocol now it's
is it the Paris of quarters it was the
Montreal agreement the Paris Accord
Dakota protocol I can't remember the
exact name the Louisiana Purchase we're
now yes we're now in Paris right now and
what they'll say is well all the
scientists agreed on this when it
devastates the economy of the world
permanently you need to know Green
policy would devastate the economy of
the world permanently Mass death and
starvation that you can't even imagine
just take what happened with covid and
apply it to the entire globe and look at
the policies and that information is
available right now they'll say it's
only three percent it's not what
decisions did they make in the face of
information that we now know to be
accurate anyway and the only way you
learn from it is when you move forward
you say okay as many voices as possible
so that we can take in wise counsel and
make a decision they eliminated those
voices they eliminated them don't let
them eliminate yours don't let them make
you believe it hit like if you're
watching the show right now and you
understand the gaslighting that is
taking place it drives me nuts oh yeah
oh okay you feel better we get that off
your chest a little bit earlier this now
that's the beauty of it though we have
empirical
yes yeah I mean but not if we let them
write history no that's right just come
out and you know yeah as opposed
to Gerald who wants to write history yes
I am far too blonde-haired and blue-eyed
for you guys to make these that's true
we are playing with fire we are playing
with fire oh my God
that face should be guarding the Bob why
offensive on the History Channel
oh so I think this is actually is this
going to be a segment of now we're going
to get into Donald Trump and and Ron
DeSantis and I would love to hear what
you believe because this has gone back
and forth and the opinions kind of
change
um I look I like both guys for different
reasons and I have issues with both guys
for different reasons it's not me being
a fence sitter I genuinely could be
persuaded but I think that both of them
I'd much rather have Ron DeSantis in
that seat as Governor than not and I
don't want to see that guy damaged
beyond belief where he can't continue to
Be an Effective Governor right I also
like Donald Trump acting as some kind of
an influence whether he wins the general
election or the primary or not I don't
want to see either one of these guys
eliminated from the pool yet uh that's
where I am and so I just hope that we
can have somewhat of a clean primary
with more focus on Biden but someone
who's more micro political illness it's
it's time for uh Mr Third Reich Gerald
knows things
want to get AIDS
he spared all of you he spared no
expense every single time I asked for
upgrades it never is going to happen
Gerald we're not running this on a Jim
Henson budget okay fine fine I guess my
sights were set a little too high so
look Trump like you said he is turning
up the heat a little bit on Ron DeSantis
because obviously he's the front runner
in the primary if you're gonna punch at
somebody right now that's if as a
republican that's the only other
Republican really that that merits
anything and uh he actually called him
unloyal oh really yeah okay I guess we
have a clip he was running against a man
that was way up in the polls leading by
a massive amount that election was over
when I endorsed him the election was
over in Ron's favor I mean it was Ron
was getting ready to quit so I don't
know I I'm very disappointed in him
because I'm a loyal person maybe to a
fault I'm a loyal person and somebody
gets you into office and then you're
telling people well I don't know if I'll
run against the president you know I
mean life shouldn't have to work that
way but it does and that's okay too A
lot of people said loyalty doesn't mean
anything to me Loyalty means a lot he's
always talking to reporters like they're
a child like life doesn't always work
that way but that's okay too sometimes
excuse me sometimes it's about being
happy for the things we do have grateful
there's always a little lesson at the
end here's a ticker toy yeah right he
said life didn't have to be that way
people don't have to have political
ambition look I understand what he's
trying to say there but on the same day
that actually we covered it that Joe
Biden released the absolute worst I'm
gonna run for re-election campaign that
we've seen yeah um actually Trump and
we've got some quotes from him and I'd
like to implore you to read them said
that he might not even participate in
some of the primary debates but I'm
curious to what people think here's the
thing thing he's not entirely wrong on
the Loyalty issue now I don't believe in
blind loyalty to one guy correct but I
do understand if and no right here's the
thing Donald Trump's not a liar Donald
Trump is a bullshiter it's like a car
salesman right like he was going really
badly he was about to quit well that's
not true but it is true that Donald
Trump did help Ron DeSantis in his
campaign oh for sure he did throw some
weight behind him and you know what
DeSantis at that point did accept that
support but likely knowing full well
that Donald Trump was going to be
running for office so I can see why
Donald Trump thinks that's disloyal I
also understand that Donald Trump says
it's just business so he does want it
both ways but I don't think it's
completely invalid when when Trump said
I'm a loyal person I think Stormy
Daniels did a spit take somewhere she's
always doing
I can do that better let's do it again
do that again yeah let me fill my mouth
again Dave come up here she did a spit
take with someone in a Clapper I'm a
loyal person
so uh the same day Biden and now I don't
know I said that you have to read the
Trump quotes yeah I don't I read that
though yeah oh okay already sorry this
is what Trump said oh you were setting
me up all right okay all right fine
I see that everybody is talking about
the Republican debate
but nobody got my approval nobody got my
approval I know some are asking did some
people know people at all
none certainly not the best people my
people
when you're leading by seemingly
insurmountable numbers folks and you
have hostile news networks with angry
Trump and Maga hating anchors asking
quote unquote questions
why subject yourself to being liable and
abused okay he's not fully wrong about
he's right to point out the media but
all we also are the party of discussing
ideas and I think it's important we have
always had primaries for a reason so
yeah I think that's silly I think if you
could keep the calling out the media
which he does really effectively right
and also show up to debate and not Uh
crap onto Santa by saying this though
isn't he giving people reasons the
people who say he comes with too much
baggage it's almost yes kind of yeah
that's right that's the big thing so
that actually leads into this look in
the Republican primary Trump is actually
doing much better than DeSantis right
during the polling so 46 versus 31 Trump
has a commanding lead that's 15 points
right but if you get into the general
when you start to compare him versus
Biden and DeSantis versus Biden Trump
actually loses by 3.1 if you believe
polling and DeSantis wins by 1.2 percent
right DeSantis leads Biden in five the
six Battlegrounds but here's the reason
people don't trust it Donald Trump one
was it 18 or 19 out of 28 20 anyone
[Music]
I would never vote for Donald Trump so
I'm not saying that DeSantis doesn't
have a better chance I'm just saying
that if DeSantis is looking to woo Trump
people to his side pointing to polling
numbers is not going to change a damn
thing because those people don't trust
them yeah they absolutely don't trust
them and you know I think the Democrats
in some ways want Trump to win but
that's also playing with fire for them
right because they feel like because it
it would be a full court press in the
media against him DeSantis doesn't have
the traction in the media that Trump
does Trump was a draw every time you
mentioned him you got tons of views tons
of clicks tons of people watching and
CNN they got 12 people instead of 10.
right but everywhere else it was Trump
trump DeSantis doesn't do that yeah and
so maybe they're looking for the draw
but then they want him to go away
because they'll just absolutely kill him
they can't do that with DeSantis in
general they had a dinner wait wait did
you say the media can't do that with the
scientists they can't they absolutely
can but he doesn't they're going to but
they're going to make him a drug it's
not as bombastic like he's not as
entertaining it doesn't matter though
once they're going to attack him attack
him attack him attack they'll attack but
it won't have the same effect you can
either become a draw as a republican
look one of two ways sort of
professional wrestling Donald Trump just
a bull in a china shop or if you are you
know Carly fiorina is an example into my
Everlasting shame you can admonish me I
supported her in the primary she was on
our show for a minute five minutes
before she broke out as a star then she
hired the Mitt Romney advisors but she
gains traction not by being bombastic
but by being by being surgical like in
her precision and just cutting up people
in the media and then she went away from
it right well she went away because of
her advisors yeah not because of her
ability so DeSantis could become a draw
if he's not bombastic but he is so
effective that he drives the media nuts
he could do it because they're going to
have all guns aimed at him there's
another way of becoming a republican
style you you date Lindsey Graham for a
month yes I don't know if that makes you
a star yeah
look DeSantis is actually not be more
Insanity Workout they probably do with
Shaun T right yeah how come all the high
I had a party with the donors yeah the
biggest donors and and and
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Asia right so he's in Japan right now
and he had some uh interactions with the
Japanese media on the intention to run
for president okay so Tim if you could
run that uh clip for us
what the hell was that what happened
yeah I'm sorry uh new guy Carl is having
a bit of issues uh cutting Clips uh
Pagan Carl Pagan Yeah Carl Pagan uh
needs some work on his uh editing look
you know let me go check it out real
quick right now okay yeah
[Music]
hey Carl uh we just had a clip go out on
air that was way too loud so when you
cut these things you got to make sure
it's at the right level normalize it so
we won't blow people's eardrums out
sorry Tim won't happen again all right
don't let it happen again
[Music]
foreign
hopefully that doesn't happen yeah let's
let's make sure but uh anyway look here
yeah yeah somewhere yeah when you find
him indeed we found the clip though
right we got the right clip so this is
him talking about the santis in a
potential presidential run yeah
well if I did that in Tokyo people would
probably say why didn't you do it in
Florida so so no announcement but um yo
I but I basically say you know I got
reelected in November we had a big
Landslide win so so no announcements uh
prior to the end of the legislative
session so just stay tuned
oh no no
[Laughter]
hey look on CNN they have Grimace all
right
by the way just so you know the
legislative session in Florida ends May
5th so if he's hinting at when an
announcement might come then we should
expect it here in the next week I'd like
to know and by the way smash that Rumble
button if you're watching right now and
we've told you that rumble's been the
subject of DDOS attack so anything you
can do to share the show uh we'll be
releasing some more Lost Tapes by the
way on audio on Spotify and apple where
it's just old we found these old
sketches from uh Nick used to be a guest
when this show was indicated on radio
and we would fill the commercial breaks
with random sketches like 30 minutes so
you can go and uh that's exclusively on
audio so I do want to know though I love
them where you line up and this is the
thing to like either run or don't
DeSantis is doing a lot of things by the
book which runs people the wrong way
like I don't know an exploratory
committee Donald Trump came down the
escalator he was like screw you I'm
running
yeah it was refreshing the Santas needs
to borrow if he wants to woo them a
little bit of that refreshing out of the
box and I I'm telling you I've seen this
with all these Republicans they come up
like a contender then they hire the
people they start acting like their
Champion if Rhonda santis does that and
he's surrounded by the Jeb Bush People
he's going to lose let's cut out all the
guesswork and call Soros and see who's
going to be yeah right now I'm saying
all the time
[Music]
oh all right so now let's uh uh do we
have a stinger for this yes of course oh
okay so now we're actually going to go
to you may not know this but San
Francisco May repeal the ban on doing
business with uh red states which of
course the band Led to City contracts
becoming incredibly expensive good but
who would want to do business with
Sanford San Francisco at all
statistically we're going to get into
this this brings us to the Golden State
of crime
[Music]
oh sorry I was singing by the way uh I
don't know I don't know if we have time
for this we're going to do the Kevin
Bacon and gay William I mean
we're already 45 minutes in we could we
could get through this we want to Rattle
it off quickly we haven't probably
rattle it off you guys in the chat below
how much uh gay William is going to be
on the show part of it but it's only for
like mainly going to be on Mud Club it
has to be because he is gay he is
conservative he's Cuban he is to the
right of Attila the Hun there is no you
just described DeSantis yeah okay
[Music]
you're the primary with a 10 000 people
good for you doesn't this no
announcement oh good for you
how do you learn to do that
it's a scale like anything else but
unfortunately in World War II was he
stuck in a rat oh no I had a French
Canadian grandfather they all dodged so
they got the easy beaches like Juno and
sword oh yeah you ever seen the video of
Juno Beach so it's like you know we had
almost uh yeah Omaha and was it gold was
uh one of them yeah gold Omaha Beach and
then Canada had Juno Beach and they had
us watched because there were cameras
back then you know like The Flintstones
like a pterodactyl like yeah absolutely
this job so so there are cameras in
Omaha and of course the America it was
like Saving Private Ryan blown up right
away and they had us watching the videos
uh in high school going so we're going
to show you the invasion of of Juno
Beach the Canadian troops and we warn
you it's very disturbing and it's just
the the boat door opens
and they just walk out into the Mist
it's like yeah
plenty died later on but the point is
they weren't really paying attention
they were like what do we do about Juno
Beach who's coming it's a Canadian side
I'll put down some gum right you pan
over to Omaha and it's Saving Private
Ryan yeah
I think I twisted my ankle now it's like
band it's like Baywatch yes it's like
the opening of Baywatch some hot German
bread and we appreciate the Canadian
soldiers of course we don't know
absolutely it was just it was Utah and
Omaha the two hardest ones and then gold
was it uh Juno gold sword I think and
Malibu that was a yeah that really
was well you lose signal in that Canyon
every time yeah I think Bert con be good
shot what two was one for you two miles
Inland Canadians like this and gets
everywhere oh my gosh
I met a lot of the Canadians when I did
a USO tour in Afghanistan yeah back then
they were tough guys absolutely I love
them loved them yeah just not World War
II they are important Willie just
kidding Canadians Gold Beach
brings us back to the Golden State of
crime the wonderful State of California
look at that look why would you want to
do business in a city where you have
inventory locked away so to give you an
idea what's happening in San Francisco
look at Target and they have to treat
the merchandise like the Hope Diamond
no audio on this car there's no audio
look at this look what's in it it's
hairspray
[Music]
plus Colgate don't call yourself Target
yes sir start there stupid
by the way not locked up small condoms
yes yes
plenty available they have the Crest
toothpaste like yeah but plenty of aim
that's just at the front no one good aim
oh my God I forgot about that I use that
because I was poor when I lived in New
York City I had canker sores for like
five months magenta said how do you have
so many canker sores I said well it goes
what toothpaste to use I go this he goes
Amber get that out of here
I use it as lube you should see that oh
that makes sense why you ended up in the
my dentist said
and by the way of course theft burglary
they were all up dramatically in San
Francisco last year why is that yeah
yeah
and elsewhere in town hoodlums they took
over the Bay Bridge and I know what
you're saying what do you mean no they
took over the Bay Bridge there were some
people there no think of the bridge yeah
as it exists yeah and it's not taken
over the opposite of that which connects
it to Oakland here you go I'd show on
the Bay Bridge involving dozens of
bikers blocked traffic Bound for San
Francisco video posted to Twitter shows
nearly 100 motorcycles stretched across
all Lanes of the Bay Bridge Sunday
afternoon Witnesses tell KTVU that as
traffic slowed down and stopped
altogether bikers began a sideshow and
some Riders drove in circles on their
back wheels in the middle of the Bay
Bridge okay now I know what you're
thinking Nick I can see what Nick's
thinking he's thinking okay you conquer
and take over my bridge once shame on me
but this isn't the first time it's
happened here's another one from last
December now look at this from late
Friday night several cars spinning
Donuts across all Lanes eastbound that
was me trying to get home in high school
stood around the sideshow
that
was lizzo's driver just fished
I said take a left oh
I would honestly I don't I have you been
over the Bay Bridge before yes oh my
goodness one it is hell to get to
because it's just traffic jammed I
thought I meant Oakland it's expensive
you're trying to get out of Oakland at
this point right not get shot if you can
see Freedom just across the water not
anymore though yeah and then you get up
there I would
if I had a weapon I would probably be
tempted to start shooting because you're
that frustrated just to get over the
bridge much less having people close it
down and by the way people
foreign
[Music]
all right we've gone through all the
statistics this is a little bit of fun
would you want to do business in those
conditions and now they have to do
business with the other states who do
things you know the exact opposite way
is them so New York Times Gavin Newsom
California they want the rest of the
country to be New York San Francisco
can't we just be results oriented at
some point in time I think so and if he
gets even one vote well people agree
with me on my theory about the election
Gavin Newsom yeah even
[Music]
thank you
at the the beaches and how just
difficult they were oh this is about is
this from World War II yeah all right
let me see it
is this Juno Beach this is Juno okay so
picture Saving Private Ryan right now
and this is the Canadian Beach the doors
are already open again I appreciate that
they went out there
the guy has a lunch pail
what are you kidding me it's like he's
going to Sandals Resort yes
I hear they got great shrimp yeah shrimp
Jamaica Hedonism too look at this look
at this I remember they told us in high
school like we this is very disturbing
and I was watching this going wait I saw
Saving Private Ryan is this it's not
working did they lie Ted it's safe get
the hibachi
who's got the football
[Music]
it was Canadian military it's Nerf or
nothing so this has been Golden State of
crime
[Music]
thank you
okay so actually I want to have him
ready before we go yeah to Mud Club so
first let me set this up for you before
he comes in we're about to go to mug
club and by the way Nick depalo of
course you can go to nickdapaloshow.com
his show is 5 P.M Monday through
Thursday go see his live shows May 12th
in Florida Daytona Beach May 19th May
20th we're about to discuss the topic
that I really want to discuss today yeah
because I used to be a fan
but uh Kevin Bacon we're going to bring
in gay William yeah again you guys
should know and just let us know in the
chat let Gay William know you love him
because this is a tough life to live a
cube a Latino gay conservative this
weekend Kevin Bacon posted a tick tock
of himself dancing with a shirt saying
that drag is Art drag is right we have
another newer clip but let's start with
this one and I keep my side of the
street please
[Music]
all right so we're going to be talking
about that and more on Mud Club but it's
time for his wonderful Stinger so it's
going to be a gay Williams segment
[Music]
Senor William do you prefer the new mask
I look at the Mexican
do you like the map what did you say
William I look like a Mexican well yeah
I know
[Music]
we appreciate it but YouTube we're gonna
continue with gay William it is thank
you so much if you're watching by the
way
foreign